hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into
practice I've studied and taught
Philosophy for over 20 years and I find
that many people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured but the
concepts themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them
useful what you're currently watching is
part of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on One Core concept
from an important philosophical text I
hope you find it useful as
well one of the key points that Emmanuel
Kant wants to make in his proma to any
future metaphysics specifically in the
Preamble on the peculiarities of all
metaphysical cognition has to do with
the kind of judgments and cognitions and
propositions that metaphysics proper is
going to be concerned with metaphysics
understood as an actual science and what
he's going to do is make a distinction
between analytic and synthetic and then
say that prop Al speaking metaphysical
judgments or statements or cognitions
are going to be synthetic and this is
occurring in a uh subd discussion in
number three in the second part of of
this
Preamble so first we should start out by
thinking about well what are synthetic
judgments Kant calls them
ampliative um he also says that they
increase the F grossen the given
cognition what what it is that we know
and so you know the
wordness can mean cognition it can also
mean knowledge and this is going to be a
really critical point that is getting
made several times throughout this
Preamble if metaphysics is actually
going to be a science a visen shaft
which kind is quite clear at the point
that he's writing it isn't right this is
a proma to not only a future metaphysics
but a possible metaphysics a real
metaphysics if that's going to occur
metaphysics is going to have to be able
to advance to add something to our stock
of knowledge about things it cannot be a
merely analytic activity just unpacking
what's already there so K will talk
about synthetic judgments as containing
in the predicate something that is not
there in the subject now what does this
mean we don't use these terms all that
frequently the subject is what something
is being said about and the predicate is
what is being said about it so if I say
this tie is blue tie is a subject or
this tie rather and is blue is the
predicate some people want to say that
is is a cop of that's fine right doesn't
really matter that much is blue is
something that is adding to the meaning
to the concept we could say of this tie
and this is an empirical judgment right
Which con says are all a poori they're
uh all um you know synthetic great that
that's fine now what about
metaphysical judgments um he is going to
give us an
example of this actually both uh
analytic and synthetic so let's look at
the one that he says first all bodies
are extended he says listen when I do
this you might not have realized that to
be a body means to have extension or to
be extended in space but that's what it
means to be a body so the predicate is
extended is contained in the subject
this is an analytic judgment we can
clarify things but we're not adding
anything new to our our stock of
knowledge about matters if we look at
another one some bodies have
weight okay this is actually adding
something now this is not a metaphysical
judgment per se this is more a judgment
in in physics right or natural science
however you want to understand
it but it is a great example of a
synthetic judgment mathematical
judgments in large part will also be
considered to be synthetic as well but
we're going to talk about those
separately and um Kant is going to tell
us in this more General discussion that
um some you know there are synthetic a
posterior judgments of empirical origin
putting them aside for the moment there
are also others which are certain a
priori we can you know say they they are
correct
without having to make any reference to
any experience
whatsoever and these spring he says from
Pure understanding and reason these two
absolutely Central faculties in
kant's understanding of of the human
mind right understanding is a lower
faculty than reason but they they're
both being used in these cases and he
says that um where do these actually
arise from uh they can't spring from the
principle of analysis namely the
principle of contradiction or
non-contradiction alone but require a
quite different principle and we're not
actually going to get that in this part
of the book but we do get that we have
some synthetic judgments a
priori now when he turns to talking
about metaphysical judgments and again
Kant will somewhat interchangeably talk
about judgments
propositions and cognitions so the
metaphysical let's just say as such or
uh the G the German term here is I link
which is translated as properly
so-called authentically genuinely we
could say right um so properly called
metaphysical judgments according to Kant
are in fact all synthetic what does this
mean well not only is the predicate not
contained in the subject but if they're
actually correct we're learning
something in the process by forming
these judgments by expressing these
judgments so metaphysics can advance can
make progress as a science not just by
engaging in analysis but by adding Bit
by Bit by Bit to our stock of knowledge
of the op prior
things that can be known a priori
synthetically right now that doesn't
mean that every single thing that we
typically call
metaphysics qualifies as synthetic there
are going to be some things that are
actually analytic and he says that these
are those that belong to
G like they belong to genuine or
properly so-called metaphysical
judgments many of which not all of which
interestingly but many of which are
analytic and what do these do these as
he says afford US a means to
metaphysical judgments uh
proper so they give us you know some
examples of this he says if there is
Concepts belonging to metaphysics for
example that of substance one that Kant
refers to quite a bit the Judgment
springing from simple analysis of them
ALS belong to metaphysics for example
substance is that which only exists as
subject Etc by means of several such
analytic judgments we seek to arrive at
the definition of a concept so analytic
judgments are okay they help us to
clarify but they don't add anything new
they don't help us advance in
metaphysics right and he says that um
you know the Judgment that all the
substance and things is permanent
that is a synthetic and properly
metaphysical judgment so this is a a
great uh case what's going on there
saying that uh substances are permanent
or
lasting right that is adding something
new to this concept of substance that
we're using if it's actually
true then we are making some progress by
figuring the this out Kant is going to
be very careful about what constitutes
making progress all of these synthetic a
priori judgments or cognitions or
propositions they need to be grounded on
something you can't just like look
around and think to yourself I'm going
to come up with some synthetic priority
judgments no no you've got to actually
have some sort of basis and he's going
to consider one
potential basis and this is in section
4 and he talks about uh what get called
the principle of sufficient reason in
German
Z right desres and this is the idea and
and it's formulated for example by Li
Nets that um in in the case of things
that we can't base on non-contradiction
there has to be some
efficient reason or grounding Foundation
cause for why they are the way that they
are and Khan points out hey this is a
synthetic AR priori judgment we don't
actually know if it's true or not people
are certainly using it he says that when
you point to synthetic judgments like
the principles of sufficient reason
which you've never proved as you ought
to from Pure reason a priori you lapse
when you try to use them for your
principal purpose into inadmissible and
uncertain assertions and this is how we
get to bad metaphysics metaphysics that
doesn't really deserve the name or title
right and so what does Kant actually
want to do what does he say that he's
done in the critique of pure
reason he's um afforded to us the
possibility of making you know reliable
lasting progress by means of synthetic
judgments about the metaphysical matters
that are all op priori so this is you
know an important little discussion
the uh propositions that form the you
know the science to be of metaphysics
some of them can be analytic there's
there're Little Helpers but the real
core of it is going to be synthetic a
priori judgments that constitute the
advances in this science of
metaphysics